I wanted to ask you um for for you guys
cuz I had bizar on the show maybe a year
ago maybe seven or eight months ago and
bizaar gave you guys a lot of love and
respect and flowers [__] yeah but you
guys had the beef right yeah yeah and
you guys were beefing with Eminem when
he was the biggest r in the world yeah
right yeah and um that had to be
interesting great publicity for you guys
a lot of new people discovered you guys
through that [__] yeah so what was that
like how serious cuz you guys are in the
same city each of you guys I'm sure are
wrapped up with some serious guys I mean
you know it wasn't like I always tell
people the problem wasn't Us in Eminem
it was our camps you know what I'm
saying run running into each other that
was the problem it was like almost like
the entourages kept that's what I'm
saying you know Throwing Fire on the
Flames our guys go all out Jugo
everywhere you know I mean Psychopathic
everywhere you know and um yeah man you
know that was what was stale but but um
man like like you know the thing
is what was the what was the point I was
can say you could go to like I keep back
then I could go to a Eminem Show right
and um
wear ICP [__] would a kid get beat up
you know what I'm saying at at an Eminem
concert no and I if he had IP [__] other
way around though yes that's what I'm
saying if somebody wore Eminem Hood
that's an arena that's in Arena right
we're in a small Club you know it's the
other way around don't wear [__] D2
hoodie to the ICP show but but you know
thankfully everything's cool you know
and I remember proof uh make squashing
the beef you know he seemed like he was
a peacekeeper for a lot of he was so
dope for coming over and um squashing
the bees man uh rest in peace proof he
was so dope like I was so happy to be
and honored to be included in that
because he was squashing M be for B
names yeah he was squashing beef with
Royce yeah he was squashing beef with
cuz M was going around back then
dropping crazy names you know what I
mean yeah he was and he was beefing with
a lot of underground rappers like
dilated people and Everlast and yeah em
had some random beefs yeah man yeah but
um yeah and when he came to the office
and [__] and and then we went bowling
and drinking youing with him with D12
with D12 so with the crew and with
against ICP wow so so that was our crew
yeah that's dope it was dope more
rappers should first we were at a
concert we that's how people should
resolve things let's hang out and let's
[__] Bowl man started rapping because
of me he went to my high school shout
out to Isham who's in the building
that's right um I was going to
say fago is very much a thing that I
only knew about because of y'all like my
whole life I didn't know fago was a real
thing I always thought it was just your
guys's drink right didn't know it was a
thing I mean later on I I found out like
when I grew up and like you know certain
liquor stores would carry like exotic
snacks on the west coast they'd have Foo
and then we go to Detroit and any liquor
store you walk into there's like 50
flavors it's pretty crazy yeah IO I mean
did they ever give you guys a piece of
the company they don't [__] with us
that's insane let me tell you something
the only thing they ever did for us yeah
right was give us a fagel machine in our
office
okay I'm going tell you something else
that's [__] crazy here's why they did
it right not because you guys are oh
you're ICP um you know oh dope you know
it's cuz all they know is we're probably
their biggest customer cuz you guys so
all the who else buys more Fel what like
we do other than maybe grocery dep
grocery departments but we're right in
there and they probably put fago
machines in the grocery departments all
the time too they just think we're one
of them they don't [__] know so when
you guys were launching I did they're
massive either right in Detroit the
Detroit thing we are obviously helping
these [__] massively so when
you guys are you guys are launching all
these two lers in the crowd you're pay
talk to him we have an attorney talk to
him like look man let's do something you
know like like just put out like a A
clowna or something you a special let's
do a special cover for people that want
it [__] you know I'm saying I'm
not asking you to put it in grocery
stores we'll buy them yeah but let's
work together so they never even gave
you guys show they wouldn't even let us
use their [__] name in a in a um
isn't that ridiculous what I'm saying we
ought to throw a [__] bomb in that
place allegedly
no that is crazy cuz I don't think I
think why don't they work with us I
think the [__] you're the yummy [__]
fangos I've thrown and sold what the
[__] over 30 years they better work with
us and suck my dick from the back from
the back from the back from the back
backwards twice yeah that's crazy so you
guys were buying all those two lers they
weren't giving them to you come on wow
bro we're getting them whatever the
charging you know I always wondered
right when you guys like would would map
out your tours we have to have semis
keep coming I was I was I was just
curious like on tour you know you guys
map out your tours is there like a like
the venue knows like hey look man at the
end of this show you better have a
cleanup crew cuz it's going to be sticky
of course they know cuz you guys were
launching man it used to be
wild I remember listen to this we did
back when all we had was Detroit mhm we
were we had not popped anywhere we
[__] ran Detroit though including
Toledo which is like an hour right you
know what I mean from Detroit so um this
too radio station is doing a festival
this is like [__]
94 they're doing a festival but we're
this massive local thing right right so
they put us on this festival with uh
Coolio
Outcast um
uh I don't remember right now too short
Too Short Too Short you know what I mean
and we're on there and we got
Fel half them fans you know what I mean
aren't jug you know what I mean but
there was a lot of [__] jug in there
you know and it was hype but Outcast was
like what the [__] you got fagel all
over our [__] turntables you know
what I mean you know what I'm saying
they were like yo I feel him though no
we had to pay him who the [__] are these
guys throwing soda dressed like clowns
what is going on in [__] Toledo
straight up they surrounded us I'm not
going to lie so Out cast they got mad so
you guys had they walked up on us you
know with a message one dude could have
said I but they sent 15 to say hey you
guys got to pay for these turntables huh
you guys bought new turntables yeah we
had to buy a new equipment for them you
know what I mean it's the right thing to
do yeah of course what's the best flavor
of Foo allegedly that's what I'm saying
one guy could sent that said that no for
sure you know what I'm saying but what's
your favorite flavor of Foo uh and this
is assuming that they suck your dick
from the back and apologize um I like
grape grape that's pretty basic what was
the one that we had that was like blue I
don't know I like blue no blue no bro my
favorite favorite is um that I think his
genius is it's called firework which
that's the one it's like a Bomb Pop bomb
pop that shit's fire you know how that
became a pop M fagel ran a contest think
of a flavor you know what I'm saying
somebody sent that in that's a dope
[__] idea a Bomb Pop and add some
[__] seler to or whatever we were in
Detroit and like I remember we probably
bought like nine bottles of Figo just to
try we're like bro we're never like
we're this is crazy we've never seen so
many random flavors of soda and like all
the rappers are like you got to try this
one got cream Peach they got Moon mist
Red Rock and Ry you know um they got
rock and Ry is Moon Mist was good well
rock rock and Ry is Dr Pepper okay Moon
mist is is um it's Mountain yeah yeah
you know what I'm saying no maybe it
wasn't Moon Mist I'm thinking of the
blue one yeah the one he said